Hi, I'm Anna, Akana
And you may remember me and my cats from such videos as "My Cats Review the Bubble Backpack" and "My Cats Review the Licky Brush".
Today, I'm super excited to let you know that we are sponsored by Kitty City!
So, Kitty City has generously sent us one of their cat towers,
Aren't you so excited!!!!
and my cats are going to genuinely review it.
(Ding noise!)
*Music*
Yeah!!! Oww!
I'm gonna enlist the help of my crew.
Cause that's what you do when you have to build anything at all!
Come on, friends!
*Music*
So, clearly Beetle likes it, let's see Lily's review.
(Ding noise) Yayyyyy!
Wow, two for two! Let's see how Jimmy likes it! He's cranky right now.
(Ding noise again!) Yayyyyyy!
All right, let's see how Congo likes it!
He's like "alright"...
-Anna's Friend: He was just sleeping...
(Ding noise) -Anna: He likes it!
Let's see how Abby likes it!
*Music*
Well there you have it... My cats have spoken with their bodies. They enjoy it.
I was actually quite surprised; it normally takes them a while to, like, get used to a thing.
but they were pretty chill off the bat with this. So, if you want to get your own Kitty City tower,
I'll put a link in the description below. It's pretty easy to assemble. It's affordable and as you can see they enjoy.
All right, I'm Anna Akana, stay awesome Gotham, I guess...